guys hello hello everybody good to see
you
hello hello andy hello everyone
all right let me pull up the chess space
all right here we go guys this is the
first game i want to show you it's a
dutch defense game between
lasker and thomas okay
e4 e6
it doesn't look like it will be a dutch
defense because normally they play the
dodge immediately with f5
okay but here we play c6 now we play
knight f3
f5 and as soon as we see the pawn on f5
then we know
it's a it's a dutch okay
so here uh many different ways you can
play
many people like to just play c4
knight c6 g3
bishop e7 and castle this is how many
people like to play in this position
but i didn't want to go into the main
theory in this game
uh so so laska didn't want to do that so
he played knight c3
avoiding the main theory so knight c3
i confused about me because i play these
positions personally many times as well
but today we're going to look at the
last care games it's a knight c3
and now the idea is how to try
to make e4 work we really want to do
that
we really want to play 4 but how can we
make it work
how can we make this work on guys
so please put in a chat your suggestions
i want to uh just ask you more questions
today so
let's see okay bishop g5 okay
bishop e7
bishop takes f6
the idea here because we want to play e4
we want to play four but we can't really
do that okay
so that's why we want to start out with
bishop takes c4
bishop takes e4 and then you play e4
this is a very famous game so it's
possible that some of you might have
seen this before
but it's always a good idea to review
this
now
he takes f takes c4 knight takes c4
and b6 black is trying to activate his
bishop and put it on b7 this is what
he's trying to do
just activate the bishop on b7
knight e5 blaster oscar immediately
activates his knight
now black castles bishop d3
now he plays bishop to b7
activating the bishop activating the
bishop and putting pressure on e4
it looks like black is catching up on
the development here
but the question is now how should white
try to attack here
how should white try to attack
or organize an attack
we got two knights and a bishop out
there but what else we can try to
activate
let's see here queen e2 yeah you can
play queenie too but you need something
better we need something a little bit
more active here
okay so we we
need to try to play a little bit more
active here
queen h5 is a suggestion
yeah that's a good idea queen you try
because now we're putting pressure on h7
and now there is a threat the threat is
to take on f6
so let's say it goes here take on f6
takes back animate
okay so a very strong idea and now white
black will play queen e7 and hoping that
if you capture
he's going to capture back with the pawn
and then he's defending h7
okay knight xf6 takes back and h7 is
protected
so now we don't have a mate because
queen is just guarding it
so now yeah we can try to castle sure
we can definitely castle here but better
we can do something better here
we can do something better here guys
you know but you have to calculate you
have to calculate
to find the idea
so please think and try to see what is
the idea that we can try to do here
what is the idea we can try to do
okay we have to we have to calculate
that would be the start
masood massoud that would be an
interesting start yeah
but if of course we have to go a little
bit deeper we can't just
uh sacrifice here we have to go a little
bit deeper
knight g5 is an idea fob for brits but
knight g5
is going to just play g6
and uh
i'm not sure what to do now because now
h7 is protected by his queen
if you sacrifice he takes
check you can go queen g7 for example
okay so i'm not sure what to do
with this now h7 is under attack
knight takes f6 um
yeah knight takes f6 uh nd 926
he takes back with this
and uh it's protecting
protecting h7 see we cannot go in here
and meet him
because of this guy
so here is very very important moment so
we have to come up with the
we need to come up with a spectacular
idea here
we have to come up with we have to come
up with that spectacular idea
knight g6 no no we had we had a
suggestion earlier
just we need a little bit more lines we
have a person who suggested the correct
move
but we need to go a little bit deeper
here
a little bit deeper guys
because you know when you sacrifice you
want to make sure you're going to have a
good follow-up okay
when you sacrifice you wanna make sure
you will have a
good follow-up
yeah it's a sacrifice queen takes h7
okay
now he takes back
king takes h7
then we go double check
well first of all it double check so
that means the king has to move
when double check happens opponent king
has to move
okay so he goes here
if he goes here now
what are we gonna do
if he goes here what can we do here
knight
well first let's show me the mate here
yeah it's a fork but it's also a mate
andy
fork animate right
can't go here can't go here it's
completely stuck
all right so that checkmate right there
so that doesn't work so it has to go
up it has to go up king to h6
now what do we do
yeah so that's a nice mate yeah
knight eg4 that's a correct
check because we need this knight to
control this
can't go on h7 bishop takes king cannot
go here take so he has to go here
okay he has to go here
and now
now we just need to figure out the way
we got to continue checking him
we got to continue checking him
now check h4 check is correct fob for
bridge
now has to go here
trying to escape with the king
you know it's the only square he can go
to there are not no many other
not too many squares he has so king is
almost out of squares now
hello passpond hello passpon
999 so now what's the move
guys today we have also evening lecture
at five o'clock central time
we're gonna have the puzzlers paradise
class okay
so you make sure you tune in for that
class as well okay
at five o'clock good good passpon
how you doing
so knight h5 we don't want to do knight
h5 here because
he could take our knight
then if we go check unfortunately we can
take this guy
now we can go check
check and he he runs out and he doesn't
he doesn't get made it
okay
so unfortunately we can't do that we
want to make sure we keep those knights
like that protecting each other okay
yeah hello h4h5 hello
now what's the other check we can do
here
what's the other check we can do knight
h5
unfortunately the knight is hanging if
the knight wasn't hanging it would have
been great for us but
it is hanging j3 okay
king f3
bishop e2 check can't go to e4 we take
f4 e3 so all the squares are taken he
has to go here
now king g2
check
now check he goes to g1 and
the final move of the game guys the
final move of this game
long castle like that he played k2 in
the game which is also
made but i like long castle better
because
how often you're gonna have a chance to
long castle and mate your opponent
uh it's amazing game it's amazing game
the king actually
was right here and end up all the way
here
with the queen sacrifice and the precise
follow-ups
checks we brought the king all the way
here to mate
let's go back to the
starting point right here see
this king is on g8 he is under attack
but it looks like he's got a rook bishop
a couple of pawns looks kind of
defending yeah
and now we have to start the attack
and force him to move the king so go
ahead guys let's start off here
what's the first idea
just we'll review this part again for
the people who join a little bit late
just for them to see it
this is why this game is really famous
this is why this game is really famous
and
memorable because it involves the queen
sacrifice
and then a strong follow-up okay
so we start out with this he takes
then we continue
then we continue what's the move
knight f6 if he goes to h8 what's the
mate here guys
check right perfect
and i was king h6
check
he goes here
do
check okay and go to f5 g6 and go any of
the squares to go here
check again
all the squares are taken has to go to
f3
check
check
and long castle mate
how much you can do all right very good
guys so that's the game
of lasker and thomas
all right now we're going to do a couple
of tactical positions okay
so i'll set up a tactical position for
you and we can start
i'll start with the simpler positions
and then
we can we can go to some more difficult
ones
all right white to play
and win
let's see maybe i might have to
adjust something here
all right yeah it's working fine okay
again take a couple of minutes
take a couple of minutes and uh uh
find a win and again yeah we had a
really nice simult yesterday guys we had
21 players
it was a very very tough simul i lost
two games but
one uh pretty much the rest and uh so
yeah if you missed the symbol make sure
you tune in for next saturday
it's a simon with grandmaster danish
boros so
you can play in that one next saturday
june
19th okay next saturday june 19th
so please think because it's very
important now not bishop d4 bishop d4 it
takes
queen takes e1 mate
bishop d4 he takes queen takes e1 is
just a mate
so it's not it's not going to work that
one
so we have to see what's going on with
this king
and how we take it down to throw it
looks like we have some answers i want
to give a little bit more time for
everybody
but it's a tactical sacrifice okay so
first we need to do a sacrifice
if we play rook d4 it's a possibility
andy but then he goes queen e5
so this is just uh actually he has a
check
takes and then it takes
if we take he takes it's just it's just
equal
okay this position
so we have to do something first if we
take with the queen
here on uh oh sorry
if we take here unfortunately uh
if i take with the king he has bishop h6
check taking the queen
he takes back here we take here
so it's uh yeah maybe slightly better
for white still because two rooks are
better than the queen
but it's not winning or anything okay
do
so
so
rook takes d6 correct first we eliminate
the bishop
then he takes back
then he no longer has a bishop here so
we can go check
check
and rook takes b4
and there is a background
background checkmate and very very
important that white has the move h3 in
because if you didn't have the moving
he's gonna go here and then
you don't have anything
okay so this is very very this is very
very important to remember okay
so
so here bishop is playing an important
role and
we simply need to eliminate it here okay
all right very good guys moving on to
the next one
okay
all right why to play
and win why
to play and win there is a lot of danger
here a lot of
a lot of problems in this position so
what you were going what are we going to
do
my
this
what to do now we have to do um
a very important forcing idea
oh you're welcome welcome uncle
yeah because your king is sitting under
this
very very unpleasant
uh position and discovery check so we
have to do something
so
so
what do we do here
we have to do things with a check here
because he's threatening to take our
queen
with the check so whatever plan we have
we have to make sure it's it's it it
does a check because otherwise
it's going to be a problem
okay queen takes h6 check sacrificing
the queen
he goes to g8 bishop g8 so he takes
g7 check can't go to g8 bishop is there
so it has to go here king h7
and now if we take and get a queen
he goes here and says checkmate
so it goes here what is the other move
you have
it depends uh china my it depends on
which topic
you wanna uh the book you know in which
topic
you know there is no like one book is
the best so it depends on the
topic now what do we do
we gotta keep doing with the check if
your queen now he's gonna take
so that's not gonna work
bishop g8 he takes to the rook
bishop g8 he takes to the rook
so
promote to a knight yes
i like that now it's a check with the
knight
he can't go to the g file we take take
take
so it has to go here king has to go to
h8
and once the king is on h8 what can we
do now to do a checkmate because he
didn't have any other options he can't
go
to the g file so he has to go here
and now we go rook
g8 mate because he can't take the bishop
is guarding it
and he can't go up the knight is
guarding itself
there is nothing nothing he can do and
that's a game
all right very good guys very good so
this is an important sacrifice
and then uh check
check and then we're gonna do what's
called the
under promotion okay so remember that
it's gonna be an idea called
under promotion okay so you're
promoting it into a lesser
valuable piece than a queen so on the
promotion okay
okay the next position for here
white to play and
win material
we're now looking for a mate here we're
not looking
anything like that
all right here we go guys it's white
to play and win material
okay so it's white to play and win
material here
you know it looks like block is under
some pressure he's under some pressure
here
and this and this so we have to figure
out what to do
foreign
this
so what can we do here to win material
here guys
we are just going to try to win material
here
you know we're not gonna we're not gonna
mate or anything we're just gonna try to
win some material and win the game
so
so
so we start off with i see some ideas
here
knight f6 okay that's correct because
now he cannot take back with the queen
because we're gonna win the rook okay
winning exchange so he has to go back
king h8
and now if you place king h8 what is the
winning idea
his queen is a bit overworked guys
because he's defending
uh defending c7 and then g7
what to do
so
98 absolutely perfect
now attacking this attacking this
and if he moves somewhere what do we do
now we have the g7 under attack right
perfect
so here he's stuck with the choice
either move the rook
get made it which is bad or take
but then you simply take here and your
up exchange okay a little very nice a
little combination
that leads into a win okay again we take
advantage of the overworked piece
here here we take
if he takes if he goes here
then we go 98 okay
and now just uh the pawn understand you
always have to think of these ideas this
overworked pieces when one piece is more
than
doing more than uh one thing it's
overworked you just want to take
advantage of it okay
okay
okay we're gonna do one more position
guys and then we're gonna take a little
break short break to do the second
lecture okay so this will be the last
puzzle
for this class and then we will have the
next class
in just a few minutes after
again this is this is tactics and how
you can try to
finish the game where you have a strong
position where you have a strong
initiative
okay
block to play okay
black to oh sorry white to play and win
white to play and find the quickest way
to win this
yeah you basically need to find the
breakthrough idea okay
what is that breakthrough that we have
yeah the threat you have to do a check i
agree absolutely because there is a
mating threat here
so all your moves have to be a check
again because
otherwise it's a problem
he will take our rook
so what do we start with here
what can we do here to make sure we can
win
yeah there are two checks yes rook takes
g7 correct
and rook h6 oh knight f6 is 31.
knight f6 yeah but then knight f6
he just takes
what other check you have besides this
too you have this guy
right
check
takes check
he goes back
and look g8
correct
and if he takes back with the king what
do we do
if he takes back with the king what do
we do now guys
queen two g6 mate perfect
if he goes king to g8
now you have made in two
what is the mating two here
what is your mating two idea
yeah you have to look at all the
defenses he's not gonna just
resign yeah he's not gonna throw away
the game
knight xf6 check can take
has to go here
yep and now you go queen g6
and simply check mate because it can go
back to g8
and go back to e8 very good nd yeah very
good everybody
this this was not very hard but the next
class
uh is going to be you know another game
of mine
but it's going to be more difficult
stuff okay so stay tuned